is going to be a great wednesday now it
is going to be warmer so i just want to
warn you for that yesterday was
unusually cool for june only low 90s
this morning we've got light winds out
there looking around valley
neighborhoods mostly in the 70s we had a
couple of spots in the 60s seven hills
mountains edge warming back up a little
bit now nellis the same low 70s there 69
in summerlin in the lake 73 on the strip
in green valley 72 at sunrise mountain a
little breezy up at kyle canyon at
and we've had a slight north breeze out
at red rock in the 60s this morning also
in the 60s for prompto just barely 60
degrees at indian springs back up to 70
at sandy valley mid 70s for laughlin
some mid 60s right now for kingman this
morning 70's for boulder city near 70 in
mesquite we've got 49 up in caliani and
finally back above freezing in ely this
morning at 34 with low 50's for both
reno and tonopah let's get a look at
your headlines we'll be heating back up
a very quick spike in temperatures
tomorrow above 105
and then breezy to gusty winds setting
back up starting tomorrow and really
working right into the weekend cooler
temperatures do follow though we'll be
dropping those temps right back into the
low 90s for dad's day and also
juneteenth on sunday hot
humid hazy conditions continue across
the midwest the ohio valley
thunderstorms are really firing up
though across the upper midwest and over
into the rockies that tremendous
flooding we're getting a better look at
how much area and real estate it's
really overtaking check this out and
this is
absaroki right montana
this is a beautiful farmland look at all
this rural area that's just
overflowing with flood waters there
heavy rains have been soaking this area
in montana remember yellowstone
yesterday we showed you roads like this
through the park were overtaken but also
out in other areas of montana where the
water flood water is just chewing away
at roads washing out bridges going to be
a lot of damage to these areas so a
beautiful country out there that's just
being destroyed and damaged by
all the flood flooding waters there now
flood waters way up north
nothing but dry area in the southwest
and we really need the rain but is
there's nothing in the forecast for us
arizona could be a different story we're
watching tropical storm bloss down here
off the mainland mexico
region some of this moisture is going to
get caught up into a northerly flow and
probably bring thunderstorms into
central and maybe even northern arizona
by the weekend i don't think it will
make it as far north as southern nevada
unfortunately sure wish we could get
some rain and some thunderstorms 99
today good sunshine up to 106 tomorrow
breezy tomorrow downright windy friday
into saturday but again that takes the
edge off the heat again for the weekend
we're down to low 90s we start summer
next week and we'll heat up for it at
105.